This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The United States leads the Olympics in medal awards and is just about supreme in the Sprint races. On October 16, 1968, American Sprinters Tommy Smith and John Carlos climbed onto the podium at the Mexico City Olympics to accept their medals. Yesterday, they came in first and third in the 200 meter dash. Smith had won gold. Carlos had won bronze. As the national anthem began to play, the men, both African-American, bowed their heads and raised their fists in the black power salute.
这里是 99%隐形。我是罗曼·马斯。美国在奥运会奖牌榜上领先，在短跑项目上也几乎无可匹敌。1968年10月16日，美国短跑运动员汤米·史密斯和约翰·卡洛斯登上墨西哥城奥运会的领奖台领取奖牌。前一天，他们在200米短跑中分别获得了第一名和第三名。史密斯赢得了金牌。卡洛斯赢得了铜牌。当国歌开始奏响时，这两位都是非裔美国人的运动员低下了头，并举起拳头行“黑人权力”敬礼。
That's producer Claire Monde. They kept their fists raised until the last notes of the anthem faded away. The gesture was a statement of black pride and defiance. It's still considered one of the anthem faded away. The gesture was a statement of black pride and defiance. It's still considered one of the most overtly political statements made in the history of the modern Olympic games. But that wasn't the only politically significant moment at the Olympics that year. A Mexican herdler named Enrique de Bas Basilio became the first woman to ever light the Olympic Cauldron.
那是制作人克莱尔·蒙德。他们一直举着拳头，直到国歌的最后一个音符渐渐消失。这个手势是对黑人尊严和反抗的声明。它仍然被认为是国歌渐渐消失。这个手势是对黑人尊严和反抗的声明。它仍然被认为是现代奥运会历史上最具公开政治色彩的声明之一。但这并不是当年奥运会上唯一具有重大政治意义的时刻。一位名叫恩里克·德·巴西利奥的墨西哥跨栏运动员成为历史上第一个点燃奥运圣火的女性。
A Czech gymnast beat out Soviet gymnast for the overall women's title, just two months after the Soviet invasion of Czechoslovakia. It was also the first time a Latin American city, or even a Spanish-speaking country, had hosted the games. It was a big deal to have hundreds of thousands of international travelers come visit Mexico. The Mexican government saw the Olympics as an announcement to the world. Mexico City had arrived as a major international metropolis. So almost everything about the 1968 Olympics felt revolutionary.
就在苏联入侵捷克斯洛伐克两个月后，一名捷克体操运动员在女子全能项目中击败了苏联体操运动员。这也是历史上第一次由拉丁美洲城市、甚至是一个西班牙语国家主办奥运会。成千上万的国际游客来访墨西哥，这是一件大事。墨西哥政府将奥运会视为向世界的宣告。墨西哥城已经作为一个重要的国际大都市崭露头角。因此，关于1968年奥运会的几乎所有事情都让人感觉具有革命性。
Including the design of it, the images and logos associated with the 1968 Olympics were ubiquitous at the time. They were plastered all over the city. This complete design campaign would become one of the most famous in Olympic history, and it would set a whole new standard for games to come. But these government commission designs would also be co-opted by local activists who wanted to reveal the darker political reality in Mexico that was hidden behind the beautiful glossy imagery of the 1968 games. In the decades leading up to the 1968 Olympics, Mexico had gone through a period of major economic growth.
包括其设计在内，与1968年奥运会相关的图像和标志在当时无处不在。它们被贴满全城。这一完整的标志设计活动将成为奥运会历史上最著名的活动之一，并将为未来的奥运会树立全新的标准。但这些政府委托的设计也被当地的活动人士所利用，他们想要揭露隐藏在1968年奥运会美丽光鲜形象背后的墨西哥更黑暗的政治现实。在1968年奥运会之前的几十年里，墨西哥经历了一个重大经济增长时期。
It became known as the Mexican Miracle. The Mexican Miracle typically, you know, historians conventionally speak about it as a period spanning from the mid-1940s to the late 1960s. The country had rapidly industrialized, rapidly urbanized, and its capital, Mexico City, had grown into this enormous sprawling metropolis. The city grew faster than it ever had in Mexico's modern history. That's Luis Castaneda. He's the author of Spectacular Mexico, design propaganda in the 1968 Olympics.
它被称为“墨西哥奇迹”。墨西哥奇迹通常，你知道的，历史学家通常认为它是一个从20世纪40年代中期持续到60年代末的时期。该国迅速实现了工业化和城市化，其首都墨西哥城已经成长为一个巨大且不断蔓延的大都市。这座城市的增长速度超过了墨西哥现代史上的任何时期。那是路易斯·卡斯塔涅达。他是《壮丽的墨西哥：1968年奥运会的设计宣传》的作者。
Because of its size and layout, Mexico City was a challenging place to host a major international event like the Olympics. Mexico City was sprawling and spreading still at the height of its miracle. I mean, even until the Olympics are literally about to happen, there are all these doubts about whether the Mexican government will be organized enough to undertake the whole aspect of all of that magnitude. The Olympic organizers needed to show that their metropolis was safe, navigable, cohesive, and, you know, exciting.
由于其规模和布局，墨西哥城是一个举办奥运会这样的大型国际活动的具有挑战性的地方。在其奇迹的鼎盛时期，墨西哥城依然在蔓延扩张。我的意思是，甚至直到奥运会即将举行时，人们还在怀疑墨西哥政府是否有足够的组织能力来承担如此巨大规模的各个方面。奥运会组织者需要展示他们的大都市是安全、易于导航、具有凝聚力的，而且，你知道的，令人兴奋的。
They wanted to create a visual identity for the Olympics to really sell Mexico City to all these visitors seeing it for the first time. So, they decided to hold an international competition to find a designer who would create a logo and graphic design campaign for the Olympics. They wanted something that looked cosmopolitan and contemporary and distinctly Mexican.
他们希望为奥运会创造一个视觉识别系统，向所有第一次看到墨西哥城的游客真正推销这座城市。因此，他们决定举办一场国际比赛，寻找一位为奥运会创作标志和平面设计活动的的设计师。他们想要一种看起来既具世界主义和现代感、又具有鲜明墨西哥特色设计。
And this is where an unlikely character comes in. I'm Lance Wyman. I'm a designer. I work here in New York. In 1966, Lance Wyman was a 29-year-old graphic designer. When he heard about the competition, he knew that he and his design partner, Peter Murdoch, had to get on the short list of contenders.
这就是一个意想不到的人物登场的地方。我是兰斯·怀曼。我是一名设计师。我在纽约工作。1966年，兰斯·怀曼是一位29岁的平面设计师。当他听说这场比赛时，他知道他和他的设计合伙人彼得·默多克必须入围候选名单。
This list included design teams from all over the world who would come down to Mexico City for a two week trial run. After their two weeks, each team would present their design for consideration. And we got on the list to go down in November of 1966. And Peter and I had just started out, we didn't have any money, so we only could only afford one- way tickets. They hopped on the plane with their one way tickets and landed in Mexico City. By the way, neither of them had ever visited Mexico before.
这份名单包括来自世界各地的设计团队，他们将来到墨西哥城进行为期两周的试用期。两周后，每个团队将展示他们的设计以供审议。我们在1966年11月进入了去那里的名单。我和彼得刚开始创业，我们没有任何钱，所以我们只买得起单程机票。他们拿着单程机票跳上飞机，降落在墨西哥城。顺便说一句，他们俩以前从未去过墨西哥。
They didn't really know anything about the country. If they were going to design a logo to represent Mexico, Wyman and Murdoch would have to learn a lot and fast. They started where most tourists start by visiting museums. It's been a lot of time at the Museum of Anthropology, where they studied artifacts from pre-Columbian Mexico, like the Aztec Sunstone and ancient Mayan murals. I actually was floored by some of the early cultures
他们对这个国家一无所知。如果他们要设计一个代表墨西哥的标志，怀曼和默多克就必须快速了解很多东西。他们从大多数游客开始的地方——参观博物馆开始。他们在人类学博物馆度过了很多时间，在那里他们研究了前哥伦布时期墨西哥的文物，比如阿兹特克太阳石和古代玛雅壁画。我实际上被一些早期文化震撼了
because they were doing things in a contemporary way with geometry and with graphics. The bold lines and bright colors and geometric shapes reminded Wyman of the kind of op art that was popular among contemporary artists back in New York. Op art or optical art uses contrast, geometry, and other tricks to give the viewer the impression of movement. And so, informed by both indigenous artifacts
因为它们正在以一种当代的方式运用几何和图形做事。醒目的线条、明亮的色彩和几何形状让怀曼想起了当时在纽约当代艺术家中很受欢迎的欧普艺术。欧普艺术或光学艺术利用对比、几何和其他技巧给观者以运动的印象。因此，受本土文物
and modern art art, Wyman came up with a logo that rift on the five rings of the Olympic symbol. I realized that the geometry of the five rings could be integrated with the year of the event, 68. He superimposed the digits six and eight over the classic Olympic rings. The circles on the rings radiated out from the circles in the digits 6 and 8 over the classic Olympic rings. The circles on the rings radiated out
和现代艺术的启发，怀曼设计了一个取材于奥运五环标志的标志。我意识到五环的几何形状可以与赛事年份“68”结合起来。他将数字6和8重叠在经典的奥运五环之上。环上的圆圈从数字6和8中的圆圈向外辐射，经典奥运五环上的圆圈向外辐射
from the circles in the digits and it created a hypnotic stripe effect. And from that, I developed the typography to make the word Mexico. It's this very groovy looking typography made of three parallel stripes. Wyman created a logo that he considered both very modern and quintessentially Mexican. The end of the two weeks came and we started making prints
从数字中的圆圈向外辐射，创造出一种催眠般的条纹效果。以此为基础，我开发出了构成“Mexico”这个词的字体。这是一种非常时髦的、由三条平行条纹组成的字体。怀曼创作了一个他认为既非常现代又具有典型墨西哥特色的标志。两周的时间结束了，我们开始打印
of the Mexico 68 logo type and people from publications and people from the public relations. They wanted copies of it and we were working like crazy making copies and doing all of that. And then Wyman realized that no one actually told him yet if he had the job. So he asked one of the organizers. I said, did we win? He goes, well, I guess so.
“墨西哥68”标志的字样，出版界和公共关系界的人都想要它的副本，我们像疯了似地制作副本并做所有这些事情。然后怀曼意识到还没有人告诉他是否得到了这份工作。所以他问了其中一位组织者。我说，我们赢了吗？他说，嗯，我想是的。
Wyman had created a stunning logo and typeface for the competition. But choosing this white guy who had never been to Mexico before was a bit problematic. It's not that unusual for people not born in Mexico for artists and people in culture and the arts to be involved with these kinds of state-sponsored campaigns. It's not entirely unprecedented, but it's still a very unique situation, especially given the fact that this is a very, very significant project. That's author Luis Castaneda again. What is very striking, almost shocking, perhaps,
怀曼为比赛创造了一个令人惊叹的标志和字体。但是选择这个从未去过墨西哥的白人小伙子有点问题。对于非墨西哥出生的人来说，对于艺术家以及文化和艺术界的人士参与这类由国家赞助的活动并不那么罕见。这并非完全前所未有，但它仍然是一个非常独特的局面，鉴于这是一个非常非常重要的项目的事实。那是作家路易斯·卡斯塔涅达。非常醒目，甚至可以说是令人震惊的是
is that the fact that of course Lance Wyman is very much unproven as a designer, he's very young, he hasn't had much time to do much yet, and yet somehow he's given this very high degree of responsibility as part of the design campaign. Wyman and Murdoch ended up staying in Mexico for two years to work on the campaign. And along with the team of designers, many of them Mexican. They came up with ways to use their typeface, logo, and other designs all over the city. The hypnotic stripes were turned into striped uniforms for the events, workers, and volunteers. The patterns and colors used in the logo ended up on hats, posted stamps, balloons, all sorts of products
这样一个事实，即兰斯·怀曼作为一名设计师当然非常未经证实，他很年轻，他还没有多少时间做太多事情，然而不知何故，他被赋予了作为设计活动一部分的极高程度的责任。怀曼和默多克最终在墨西哥逗留了两年以开展这项活动。他们与许多是墨西哥人的设计团队一起，想出了在整个城市使用他们的字体、标志和其他设计的方法。催眠般的条纹变成了赛事工作人员和志愿者的条纹制服。标志中使用的图案和颜色最终出现在帽子、邮票、气球以及各种各样的产品上
to hype the impending games. And these objects range from very small objects, all kinds of memorabilia, things from ash trays and furniture or apparel, all the way to the stadiums. Stadiums across the city were painted with these radiating op-art patterns. Bright colors decorated sidewalks and walls and plazas. And these bright hypnotic designs
为了炒作即将到来的比赛。这些物品从非常小的物品、各种纪念品，从烟灰缸、家具或服装，一直到体育场。全城的体育场都画上了这些辐射状的欧普艺术图案。明亮的色彩装点着人行道、墙壁和广场。这些明亮迷人的设计
didn't just give the Olympic Games a visual coherence. The graphic design language of the Olympics expanded into an entire system that helped visitors navigate the massive metropolis. To do this, Wyman made simple color-coded icons to represent every sporting event. They were not stick figures, but they were focused more on a part of the body or piece of the equipment or a combination of the two.
不仅赋予了奥运会视觉上的连贯性。奥运会的平面设计语言扩展成了一个完整的系统，帮助游客在这座庞大的大都市中导航。为此，怀曼制作了简单的颜色编码图标来代表每一个体育赛事。它们不是火柴人，而是更多地聚焦于身体的一部分、一件设备或两者的组合。
Gymnastics, for example, was represented by a hand gripping a single suspended ring. Track and field, head its icon, boxing head its icon. So on a ticket, you knew what your ticket was for by the icon only. So if you're visiting from Japan and didn't speak any Spanish, you'd see, say, the soccer icon on a green background, and you'd follow the green signs to the stadium where the soccer would be. And the system wasn't just for sports. Why I'm in the team made universally understandable icons for 19 cultural events happening around the city as well.
例如，体操由一只抓着单个悬吊环的手来代表。田径有它的图标，拳击有它的图标。所以在票上，仅凭图标你就知道你的票是做什么用的。因此，如果你是从日本来访且不会说任何西班牙语，你会看到，比如说，绿色背景上的足球图标，然后你会沿着绿色标志走到举行足球比赛的体育场。这个系统不仅适用于体育运动。怀曼和团队为全城正在发生的19项文化活动制作了普遍易懂的图标。
We had children's painting, we had folk dancing, we had science programming. By following these cultural icons, visitors could continue to entertain themselves and explore the city after the sporting events were over. The 1968 Olympics had been to create Los Huegos de la Paz, the games of peace. So Wyman designed a little outline of a dove, which shop owners all over the city were given to stick in their windows. Between the logo, the typeface, the colors, the icons, and the doves, Wyman created a visual identity that saturated the whole city. It was everywhere.
我们有儿童绘画，我们有民间舞蹈，我们有科学节目。通过跟随这些文化图标，游客在体育赛事结束后可以继续自娱自乐并探索这座城市。1968年奥运会旨在创造“和平运动”（Los Huegos de la Paz）。因此，怀曼设计了一个小鸽子轮廓，全城的店主都被分发了这个轮廓贴在他们的窗户上。通过标志、字体、颜色、图标和鸽子，怀曼创造了一个饱和了整个城市的视觉形象。它无处不在。
It was a total design campaign. Total design campaign, right? The idea of total design, that every single thing, idea, place, object associated with the Olympics, is immediately and powerfully recognizable as part of a whole. And the completeness of the campaign would set a precedent for years to come. I think it's safe to say that, although design and architecture and the arts in general had been very powerfully associated with Olympics before Mexico 68, it's really after Mexico's succeed that it becomes a kind of standard expectation of design campaigns associated with these kinds of events. While Lance Wyman was designing this extensive campaign, he was holed up, swammed with work,
这是一个全面的设计活动。全面的设计活动，对吧？全面设计的理念是，与奥运会相关的每一个单一的事物、想法、地点、对象，都被立即且强有力地识别为一个整体的一部分。而活动的完整性将为未来几年树立先例。我认为可以肯定地说，尽管设计、建筑和一般艺术在“墨西哥68”之前就已经与奥运会有着非常强烈的联系，但真正是在“墨西哥68”成功之后，它才成为与这类事件相关的设计活动的一种标准期望。当兰斯·怀曼在设计这个广泛的活动时，他被困住了，被工作淹没了，
and he really didn't get a chance to go out much. No, so the grindstone really, almost through the whole thing, we were pretty isolated at the Olympic Committee. He didn't see the protest movement growing in the city around him. The movement was led by students who believed the long-ruling institutional revolutionary party catered to wealthy Mexicans rather than the poor, rural, and working class. The country had been experiencing huge economic growth, but millions of people had been left behind. The country had been experiencing huge economic growth, but millions of people had been left behind. The Mexican miracle hadn't reached everyone. The government was talking of the Mexican miracle. Even though in the reality of
他真的没有机会出去走走。不，所以基本上从头到尾我们都在埋头苦干，我们在奥组委相当孤立。他没有看到周围城市中不断增长的抗议运动。这场运动由学生领导，他们认为长期执政的体制革命党迎合了富有的墨西哥人，而不是穷人、农村和工人阶级。这个国家一直在经历巨大的经济增长，但数百万人被落在了后面。这个国家一直在经历巨大的经济增长，但数百万人被落在了后面。墨西哥奇迹并没有触及每个人。政府在谈论墨西哥奇迹。尽管在现实中
those days things were not as happy as they appeared. These are excerpts from interviews with students involved in the protests against Mexico's single party government, courtesy of our friends at Radio Diaries. In the 60s, we were still accounted where the government controlled everything. Presidents were the equivalent of monarchs. I mean, it was forbidden to demonstrate
那几天的情形并不像表面上看起来那么快乐。这些是采访参与抗议墨西哥一党制政府的学生的摘录，由我们的朋友《电台日记》（Radio Diaries）提供。在60年代，我们仍然是一个政府控制一切的账目。总统相当于君主。我的意思是，示威是禁止的
you could not go and express your dissent. And for the students protesting the government meant protesting against the Olympics themselves, the so-called Games of Peace. Olympics are, I think, maybe by design by definition, always about propaganda on some level or another. And so what the Olympics sought to present as a kind of happy picture of social harmony
你不能去表达你的异议。对于抗议政府的学生来说，这意味着抗议奥运会本身，即所谓的“和平运动”。我认为奥运会，也许由于设计由于定义，在某种程度上总是关于宣传的。因此，奥运会试图呈现的那种社会和谐的快乐图景
and as a kind of very sanitized idea of how modernization happens was of course not the reality of what many of these inhabitants of the city experienced. Tens of thousands of protesters took to the streets repeatedly throughout 1968. We were urban middle class, low middle class, bunch of job people. It was in a symbolic way the clash of a new Mexico and a non-Mexico. You have a middle class with eyes closed and a group of students saying this was not a democracy
以及那种关于现代化如何发生的非常美化的想法，当然不是这群城市居民所经历的现实。在整个1968年，成千上万的抗议者一再走上街头。我们是城市中产阶级、中下阶层、一帮打工的人。这象征性地是一个新墨西哥和一个非墨西哥的碰撞。你有一个闭着眼睛的中产阶级，和一群说这不是民主的学生
and this is not working. Again and again, police had come out and violently dispersed protesters with clouds of tear gas as the Olympics neared and as international attention turned towards Mexico City. The government was desperate to make the unrest go away. On October 2nd, just 10 days before the games of peace were set to begin, thousands of students gathered at
这行不通。随着奥运会的临近以及国际注意力转向墨西哥城，警察一次又一次地出现并用催泪瓦斯驱散抗议者。政府拼命地想要让动荡消失。10月2日，就在“和平运动”拉开帷幕仅10天前，数千名学生聚集在
Lattaloko Square in the northeast of Mexico City to demand the release of people who had been locked up at a previous protest. It was a quiet gathering of people with signs, walking slowly around the plaza. And we'd look back and there was all these infantry troops. They started to advance towards the crowd and at some point we heard some shots. We didn't know where they came from and seconds later how do you say in English? All help broke loose. soldiers opened fire on the protesters. To this day we don't know exactly how many students died in the massacre, but the number is likely in the hundreds. The scene was cleared before there could be an accurate body count.
墨西哥城东北部的特拉特洛尔科广场（Lattaloko Square），要求释放之前抗议活动中被关押的人员。这是一个安静的人群聚会，他们拿着标语，在广场上慢慢走着。我们回过头看，全都是步兵部队。他们开始向人群推进，在某个时刻我们听到了一些枪声。我们不知道它们来自哪里，几秒钟后，英语怎么说？一片混乱。士兵向抗议者开火。直到今天，我们仍然不知道大屠杀中到底死了多少学生，但人数可能在数百人。现场在能够进行准确的尸体计数之前就被清理干净了。
The blood was washed away. Thousands of protesters were arrested and locked up. The government took great pains to cover their tracks. The amount of students were shot and many of the others were imprisoned for quite some time was covered up. The government claimed that the students had fired first to provoke the military. Evidence has since come to light
血迹被洗掉了。数千名抗议者被捕并被关押。政府煞费苦心地掩盖他们的行踪。被枪杀的学生数量以及许多其他被监禁相当长时间的人都被掩盖了。政府声称学生先开枪挑衅军方。此后有证据浮出水面
that disproves that claim. It's an extremely shocking event for a long time kind of suppressed in Mexican national memory. And in many ways, it is the crux of the crisis that sets the stage for the, in a very, very dramatic sense for the Olympics themselves. The massacre was so horribly devastating
反驳了这一说法。这是一个极其令人震惊的事件，长期以来在墨西哥国家记忆中被压制。在许多方面，它是危机的症结所在，为奥运会本身奠定了基础，以一种非常非常戏剧化的意义。大屠杀是如此可怕地毁灭性
that of course Lance Wyman heard about it. When I heard about it and how severe it was, it was a difficult situation because I felt I was working for the government and I couldn't do anything about it. But he says he really empathized with the students. I wasn't much older than they were, so I had that feeling that I might have felt good
以至于兰斯·怀曼当然听说了这件事。当我听到这件事以及它的严重性时，这是一个困难的情况，因为我觉得我在为政府工作，而我对它无能为力。但他说他真的很同情学生。我比他们大不了多少，所以我有一种感觉，如果我只是离开这一切
if I just walked away from the whole thing. Wyman felt stuck in the middle. But in a way, he didn't need to choose between the government and the protesters. His designs found a way to serve both sides. Students began imitating Wyman's images and co-opting them. They took a poster he made with a silhouetted image of runners racing and turned it into silhouettes of troops beating people with batons.
我会感觉很好。怀曼感到进退维谷。但在某种程度上，他不需要在政府和抗议者之间做出选择。他的设计找到了为双方服务的方法。学生们开始模仿怀曼的形象并将其实施盗版。他们把他制作的一张印有奔跑者剪影的海报变成了军队用警棍殴打人们的剪影。
They used his signature typography to create anti-government posters and that very simple image of a dove in all the shop windows. Students went around the city spraying a small burst of bright dove in all the shop windows, students went around the city spraying a small burst of bright red paint over the dove's chest, like it had been shot. They were playing with the propaganda of the Olympics and hinting at a darker political reality. And Wyman, he liked it.
他们用他标志性的字体制作反政府海报，以及所有店铺橱窗里那只鸽子的非常简单的图像。学生们在全城四处喷洒，在鸽子的胸前喷上一小团亮红色的油漆，就像它被枪击了一样。他们在玩弄奥运会的宣传，并暗示着更黑暗的政治现实。而怀曼，他很喜欢。
He made a design campaign so ubiquitous, so resonant that the resistance could use it too. And I've always been questioned, well, why do you feel good about that? And I guess that's why, because I was in a situation where I was kind of torn. I was very sympathetic as far as what was happening to the students, but I was also very not wanting to see the Olympics be stopped. And they weren't stopped. On October 12, 1968, the games began on schedule, as if nothing out of the ordinary had happened. 12 October, 1968, declared inaugurated the Olympic Games of Mexico. the Mexico. The 1968 Olympics went on to become one of the most important in the history of the games,
他做了一个如此无处不在、如此引起共鸣的设计活动，以至于抵抗力量也可以使用它。我一直被问到，嗯，你为什么对此感觉良好？我想这就是为什么，因为我处在一个有点纠结的境地。我对学生们的遭遇非常同情，但我也非常不想看到奥运会被阻止。而它们没有被阻止。1968年10月12日，比赛按计划开始，就像什么不寻常的事情都没有发生一样。1968年10月12日，宣布墨西哥奥运会开幕。墨西哥。1968年奥运会继续成为奥运会历史上最重要的奥运会之一，
marked not only by athletic achievement, but by open political defiance. Do you think you represented all black athletes in doing this? I can say I represented black America and very proud to be a Black man and also to have won the gold medal. Mexico 68 also set a new precedent for how governments would use design to promote their country's image to the international community for better or for worse. The 68 games also left a permanent mark on Mexico City's infrastructure. Mexico City is one of the largest cities in the world. It's the largest metropolitan area in North America. Around 4.4 million people ride on Mexico City's metro system every day, including producer Claire Mullin, who visited a couple months ago. I'm in the metro on the pink line at Quarte-Moc, which has an eagle icon.
不仅以其体育成就为标志，而且以公开的政治反抗为标志。你认为你在这样做时代表了所有黑人运动员吗？我可以大声说我代表了黑人美国，并且非常自豪能成为一个黑人男性，而且还赢得了金牌。墨西哥68还为政府如何利用设计向国际社会宣传其国家形象树立了一个新的先例，无论是好是坏。68年奥运会也给墨西哥城的城市基础设施留下了永久的印记。墨西哥城是世界上最大的城市之一。它是北美最大的大都市区。每天大约有440万人在墨西哥城的地铁系统上乘车，其中包括几个月前访问过这里的制作人克莱尔·穆林。我在粉红线的莫克苏马（Quarte-Moc）地铁站，这里有一个老鹰图标。
Mexico City's metro is incredibly crowded and very extensive, and yet it is often recognized as one of the easiest rail systems to navigate, partly because of its iconography. La Catolica, which is a big ship, it looks like a pirate ship without the pirate symbol. And then we have Merced, where there are six apples and a crate. And those icons are there, thanks in part, to Lance Wyman. The Metro was supposed to make its debut during the Olympics, but excavators kept unearthing ancient architecture in the path of the Olympics, but excavators kept unearthing ancient architecture
墨西哥城的地铁极其拥挤且非常广泛，然而它通常被认为是导航最简单的铁路系统之一，部分原因在于其图标化。圣卡塔利娜（La Catolica），那是一艘大船，看起来像一艘没有海盗标志的海盗车。然后我们有梅塞德（Merced），那里有一个板条箱里的六个苹果。而这些图标的存在，部分要归功于兰斯·怀曼。地铁本应在奥运会期间首次亮相，但挖掘机在奥运会轨道路径上不断发掘古代建筑
in the path of the tracks, and the opening was delayed. But Wyman was still involved in its design, specifically its map. He employed the same visual system he developed for the Olympics to help international visitors navigate the trains. In the Olympics, we relied on the graphics, and I thought, well, why can't a city do that? So Wyman color coded each line and created a unique icon for every single stop? So even if you're visiting from Japan and can't read any Spanish at all, you can say to yourself, I want to take the pink line to the stop of the grasshopper on it. The station that's stopped at Chipotlepec Park,
在轨道路径上，开幕被推迟了。但怀曼仍然参与了其设计，特别是其地图。他采用了他为奥运会开发的相同的视觉系统，以帮助国际游客在列车中导航。在奥运会中，我们依靠图形，我想，嗯，为什么一个城市不能那样做呢？所以怀曼对每条线路进行颜色编码，并为每一个单独的车站创建了一个独特的图标！所以即使你从日本来且完全不懂西班牙语，你也可以对自己说，我想坐粉红线到上面有蚂蚱的那个车站。在查普特佩克公园（Chipotlepec Park）停下的车站，
Chipotlepec means grasshopper Hill in the Nahuatl, the Aliasa Tech language, so I use the Grasshopper. Again, some Mexicans took issue with this young foreigner coming in to design something that would be such a huge part of their city, but eventually, Mexican designers took up the project and made it their own. You know, I designed the first three lines of the Metro and all the, they have 12 lines now and they were designed by Mexican designers and some of these are better than I did in the original line, you know.
在纳瓦特尔语（Aztec印第安语）中，查普特佩克意思是蚂蚱山，所以我使用了蚂蚱。同样，一些墨西哥人对这个年轻的外国人进来设计将成为他们城市如此重要的一部分的东西表示异议，但最终，墨西哥设计师接手了这个项目并使其成为他们自己的。你知道，我设计了地铁的前三条线以及所有，他们现在有12条线，它们是由墨西哥设计师设计的，其中一些甚至比我做的原版线路还要好，你知道的。
After the Olympics, after the Metro, Wyman did some more work for Mexico, like the design for the 1970 World Cup, but he went back to the US. Wyman went on to design more maps, big ones like for the National Zoo and the DC Metro System, although none of them used symbols and icons and colors as completely as in Mexico City. The clear iconography of the Metro System is a reminder of a complicated and sometimes terrible period in Mexico City's history. It's a simple design that invites you to explore the massive and complex metropolis.
奥运会之后，地铁之后，怀曼为墨西哥做了一些更多的工作，比如1970年世界杯的设计，但他回到了美国。怀曼继续设计更多的地图，大地图，比如为国家动物园和华盛顿特区地铁系统设计的地图，尽管没有一个像墨西哥城那样完全使用符号、图标和颜色。地铁系统清晰的图标提醒着人们墨西哥城历史上复杂有时糟糕的时期。这是一个简单的设计，邀请您探索这个庞大而复杂的都市。
It's a design that assures you that, if you get lost, no matter where you're from or what language you speak, you can find your way around and see the city for yourself. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Claire Mullin and Avery Trouffleman. Technical production and mixed by Sheree Fusef with music by Sean Rial and Ok Akumi. Our Senior Producer is Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the staff includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Teran Masa, and me Roman Mars. Thanks to the team at Radio Diaries who provided us with some of the tape from their documentary,
这是一个向您保证的设计，如果您迷路了，无论您来自哪里或说什么语言，您都可以找到方向，并亲自去看看这座城市。本周的《99%隐形》由克莱尔·穆林和埃弗里·特鲁夫曼制作。技术制作和混音由谢里·菲塞夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔和奥库·阿库米提供。我们的资深制作人是凯蒂·明格尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。其他工作人员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰尼·霍尔、特兰·马萨以及我罗曼·马斯。感谢《电台日记》团队，他们为我们提供了他们纪录片中的一些录音带，
a movement, a massacre, and Mexico's 50 year search for the truth. It tells the story of the student protests in 1968 and uncovers a secret behind the government's bloody crackdown. You can hear that story on the student protests in 1968 and uncovers a secret behind the government's bloody crackdown. You can hear that story on the Radio Diaries podcast right now. Radio Diaries is one of the OG radio topia programs. You should definitely be subscribed if you aren't already. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful,
《一场运动、一场大屠杀以及墨西哥对真相的50年寻找》。它讲述了1968年学生抗议的故事，并揭开了政府血腥镇压背后的秘密。你现在可以在《电台日记》播客上收听那个故事。《电台日记》是最初的广播乌托邦（Radio Topia）节目之一。如果你还没订阅，绝对应该订阅。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在广播街（Radio Row）制作。在美丽的、
downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show enjoying discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, we're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But we have all the old episodes and a bunch of design stories that you can only read with your eyes on our website.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。您可以在Facebook上找到该节目并讨论该节目。您可以在Twitter上@我 Roman Mars，以及节目 @99PI org，我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。但我们所有的旧期节目以及许多只能在我们的网站上用眼睛阅读的设计故事都在上面。
It's at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 99pi.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。